IRL will be live in Miami with Patrick
Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates and
Luke rowski join us there get your
tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
timcast.net Mark Zuckerberg put on his
metaverse headset and and and headphones
it then mapped his face with the cameras
all around it creating a CGI realtime
animation of him as he's talking with
Lex fridman that is wild yo this is
getting creepy and you know I can only
beg acceptance of the Mark Zuckerberg
no no it's real easy to D on the
metaverse when it looks like we like a
Wii game but now it's like yo wait a
minute you know these these you're
seeing right now that we're playing on
the screen this is
CGI now Lex looks real Mark looks a
little plastic but to be fair Mark kind
of look like I know looks which means it
looks very real it looks good right but
uh Lex blinking and sitting and sitting
right there like even his skin tone like
the differences in like you know the
tone across his face look at this uh
Pisano on Twitter said no offense but
your avatar appears more human and
lifelike than your real form
appar apparently I crashed the NVC site
man dude Mr be is commenting on this
stuff yo it's going to be crazy but
here's what you need to fear with
something like this and why we shouldn't
build it we shouldn't build it but it
doesn't matter it will be built if it's
not Zuckerberg someone will build it
it's because the more we create digital
spaces that can uh simulate reality the
closer you get to living in the pot and
eating the bugs because what's going to
happen is it's not going to be a
government mandate Joe is not going to
go listen here Jack we'll put you in the
Pod you're going to eat the bugs and
they're go no and that'll never happen
what's going to happen is he's going to
say
listen for the people who can't afford
the the rent prices we have pod
personalized occupancy device and when
you go inside of it you strap on your
Mark Zuckerberg headset and instantly
you're in a 10,000 foot mansion where
you can walk around and all your friends
are there and it's no different than
reality now why and then what happens
once
it won't just be that in fact it might
actually even be luxury at first only
the rich people can afford the super
nice metaverse things then it will
become programs for cheap metaverse
access you're going to have commercials
where it's like are you YouTube ads I
don't know we're not in the a
commercials but it's going to be like
stop spending three grand a month on
rent don't be a dumbass get metaverse
then it's going to show like this dude
put on the goggles it's not really going
to be that corny or whatever but he's
going to be in a closet it's going to be
like ready play play one meets em for
the machine stops Ready Player One the
kid lived in a trailer right trailer
stacked on top of each other at least
they had a trailer n in the in in in
this your home is going to be a bathroom
your your apartment will be a to will be
a toilet shower combo where you will go
inside you will strap into the metaverse
and lean back on like a a flat chair and
then or like like I don't know what
you'd call it not a chair but something
to lean against you'll put the headset
on grab your controllers and then this
is the start
and it only so like like Phil was saying
when it's we characters it's silly and
stupid everyone makes fun of it this
this is getting scary because now people
are going to be like you can actually
have meetings and do podcasts and
interviews and we're already there you
know about 15 years ago somebody showed
me Second Life yeah I remember they
explaining to me that and they were
super into it right yes and people sold
they made real money in the real world
selling products or concert tickets or
whatever in second life and that was 15
years ago when it was really cheesy and
like even the computers were cheesy at
that time but I'm picturing we saw well
I call them the the pajama Americans and
we saw during Co the amount of people
since then and during that just lost all
respect for themselves who just go out
to the shops now wearing their pajamas
and Crocs oh I hate that it's disgusting
like fedman yeah and they reinstituted
the dress code right and so I mean how
far it just too disgusting exactly and
we're we're subjected to this every time
we go to the grocery store now but how
far are we from the pajama Americans
being totally fine to just strap into
the metaverse and spend their fed bucks
in the metaverse getting their their
Nike you know Jordans and all I mean
totally renting renting fake clothing to
where to the
party this is why they want to do it
they want to do it because look at nfts
there is a big push for uh so uh let me
slow down gret tunberg says see idea of
infinite economic gross is insane no
their plan is digital products that can
be infinitely mass-produced have fake
value based on artificial scarcity and
then no one manufactures anything and
they're already there because you can
buy like Warcraft bro exactly you buy
and I mean in uh in Destiny 2 you can
buy different shaders and for colors for
your outfits you can buy different armor
Stu yes but with with with World of
Warcraft going back to 2006 you could
buy someone else's boots so not if it
was soulbound though right soulbound was
when you get an item and it couldn't be
traded but you would defeat a monster it
would drop an uncommon set of gloves the
forest gloves of agility or something
and then you'd go to someone and be like
do you want it and they'd be like yes
and' be like I want 10 bucks and then
You' trade it to him and then you'd get
10 bucks people were trading gold in
game so digital digital items have
already had a Marketplace and they want
to capitalize off this it's crazy to me
if you think about mobile games they
were farms in China where people just
play World of Warcraft and kill rabbits
super gold like all day long right and
then the funny thing happened when uh
World of Warcraft made it so you could
buy gold in game and it was for like you
could buy what was it how does it work
you can buy a token worth uh a one month
of gameplay and then trade the token for
26,000 gold or something destroyed the
economy really why all of a sudden so in
World of Warcraft I love there there
needs to be a research study on the E
the economics of MMOs but uh in the
beginning of the game you first start
you're super weak you walk outside and
there's like a level five Bandit or
something and you fight him and then you
take his like linen cloth from his shirt
you sell it for a few pieces of copper M
the value early on is low once you get
to higher and higher levels the bad guys
drop more money you you defeat the
Bandit now he's got gold instead of
silver instead of copper as soon as you
could buy gold people start the game and
immediately just buy a ton of gold
they're like I'm not starting the game
with no money then what happens is the
lowest quality items that no one really
needs well look if all the new players
have access to massive amounts of
currency that used to be too hard to get
it used to be like you know 50 silver
for a stack of linen cloth now it's 10
gold why because new players have the
gold so supply and demand someone's got
it and they say I'll sell it and someone
says I'll give you a gold for it no I'll
give you two I'll give you three I'll
give you four I'll give you five the
price is Skyrocket and you end up
watching inflation due to the mass
printing of money it's it's fascinating
how you could teach a 12-year-old
inflation by having play World of
Warcraft that makes sense thanks Joe
Biden thanks Joe but anyway yeah the uh
the AI apocalypse is upon us I hope you
guys enjoyed it while it lasted you are
going to live in the Pod and it's not
that you're going to eat the bugs it's
that when you do eat the bugs it's going
to taste like
cheesecake know you're going to you're
going to put on your metaverse headset
you're going to attach your wireless mag
neuralink to the base of your your your
your your neck and then when someone
hands you a bowl of uh boiled mashed
cockroaches you're going to be looking
at a delicious brown sugar oatmeal with
cream on top and they'll say that that's
good because if you're lactose
intolerant you won't have any problem
and that's right and when you're in the
the temperature controlled pod you won't
have to worry about the scary climate
change going on outside the front you
know this stuff is all predicted in our
fiction for you know like over a century
em Foresters the machine stops is really
about this everybody lives in a podt
underground because the world has become
uninhabitable and there's a machine that
pairs everybody up for mating and for
discussions there's a big view screen
and the Machine gives you everything
that you need and you never have to
leave your pod and this one woman ends
up having to leave her pod to go see her
son and she's like why do I even have to
come see you I see you on the telescreen
you know I made it with your father once
when the machine told me to or whatever
but it's very simp like we keep
predicting these things and we keep
doing exactly the thing that is going to
destroy us for the prediction I I just I
just thought of thought saw something
you know know I'm going to I'm going to
I'm going to hit up LAX where can I get
these headsets cuz we spend a lot of
money on travel costs so we can do
inperson conversations with people
flying them out getting them hotels if
we can just ship them the headset it'll
be way cheaper than flying the whole
person so it's like here be bad for the
brand yeah but no one will know the
difference they'll think they're sitting
in the room right fair enough fair I
mean to be fair this is all CGI AI
generated anyway there's no actual Tim
pool Phil's not real either the guests
are made up on the Li is the only real
person no I'm totally
fake I was constructed in a lab that's
why I get everything wrong but we're
we're really close I don't think people
realize how close we are to full AI
podcasts where the the host is going to
be fake none of the Char people are
going to be real yeah dude it's it's
it's mid journey is already crazy and we
played that uh capital of Conformity
video that video is so amazing the AI I
don't know I don't did you see it I
tweeted it out where it's like with the
future will look like and it's this this
AI generated video for the most it's AI
generated but a human put the pieces
together and uh we're we're we're we're
getting really close to the point maybe
within a year where you're looking at
this Mark Zuckerberg stuff do you even
if the computer can map his mouth in
real time to what he's saying do they
even need actually actual Mark they
don't no they just they just call from
what he's previously said as soon as
they have the picture of his face you
can program what he's saying and it will
just make it look like he's talking mhm
so you could actually be like you wake
up it's like 9:00 you're like oh I'm
late man I got a meeting in the morning
you're like you know uh computer uh put
in my avatar and have it go to work for
me and then everyone thinks they're
talking to you but it's just the AI
simulating
you saying what it thinks you're going
to say and then you're sitting at home
no everyone it's just everybody does
that it's everybody's AI right it's
just like probably you know play Gam or
whatever other degenerate things people
do on the internet what do we think like
just along these lines like what do what
do we think about like major events like
sporting events where during coid we
were conditioned to watch these events
with no audience or the NBA played in a
like a hermetically sealed dome for a
while if I recall we like how would they
just start having events and then just
AI the whole like crowd and just it's
like Black Mirror man they'll just AI
the players in Black Mirror everybody's
in that room tiny rooms where every it's
a TV screen all around them and then it
turns into the like the the show set and
they feel like they're there but then
the the set was little me characters
clapping it's going to be like it's
going to be like this do you remember
the Twilight Zone where everybody dies
except for the guy who was in the
basement and he comes out and he he was
like in the vault so this Banker was uh
just he never wants to have to go to
work so at his on his lunch break he
just goes down to the Vault of the bank
he closes the door over a little bit and
he just sits there and reads where no
one will bother him and one day there's
like a nuclear blast and everyone dies
and he comes out of the Vault and he's
just like oh my goodness this is crazy
I'm just going to read forever his
glasses and then he he breaks his
glasses yeah he he's like but you know
you know it was finally time but I feel
like that there'll be like just one
person who isn't fake and they'll
finally just realize like that they're
the only person left in the world and
everything is fake this would be a good
story and they have to make that
decision do I go into the AI metaverse
and pretend I'm fake too do I IGN it I'd
like to um add on to my propaganda short
films idea where we paint the bad guys
in a more positive propag propagandistic
light and just also make a series where
we solve really stupid problems that
shows thought were profound like when
the guy breaks his glasses he goes he
doesn't say no it was time now he breaks
the glasses and goes oh I broke my
glasses puts them back on because he can
still see just not well goes to a
glasses store where they already have
thousands of pairs sitting there and
puts on a new pair of glasses I wondered
that too instead he's just like no no
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net